what happens behind the doors of the
European Parliament national
parliamentarians discovered precisely
what
during the European parliamentary week
in Brussels for two days they exchanged
views with top EU leaders and MEP s on
the EU budget and economic policies
he says you poor do work my school Lucia
Lucia card is it a lot I pondhawk old
loo develop a new context of OPI a halo
appeared for national MPs it was also
important to let their European
counterparts know the difficulties they
sometimes experience with EU legislation
Hongkou bracel no hope no supposed
irregular back on come papa
some crazy serum a turnover in the
crucial compass do you see santa barbra
more open ly difficult a good new home
home Papa Ramadan offseason skater John
Coruscant aunt Alicia miss want initial
could only be kept up to be on the menu
we need a platform where we can exchange
our views exchange best practices
exchange ideas of how we implemented the
reforms in the various countries it's
also important for colleagues in
European Parliament to have this annual
exchange of view to see what are the
challenges economic social questions in
various countries so it helps to have a
real picture national parliaments are
vital partners for EU institutions as at
the very end of the process they have to
pass the legislation agreed in Brussels
for their own statute books